LESS THAN A MONTH,Y, FIRST OF
TWO MEETINGS BETWEEN THESESHARKS
BURNS PUTS IT ON NET AND, AND
CARRYING IT OVER ROLLS
E SAN JOSE
BENCH WITH PANTHERS.
HERE'S A CENTERING PASS OUT
FRONT FOR WILLLL
TONIGHT MORE OFTEN THAN NOT WHEN
HE'S ON THE ICE.
HERE'S HERTL, WORKS GOAL STICK
THERE TO BREAKG TO SIMEK
IT ALLOWS THAT PLAY TO COME INAD
TRAVIS KONECNY SENDS IT UP AND
THEY THREE-ON-TWO TO
RISTOLAINEN ON BACK OVER TO
>> Randy: REIMER IS GOING TO
THD
THERE'S JAMEHOLE
EXACTLY WHAT HE DOES
THISSAVED BY REIMER.
COUTUTM FORCED
S RIGHT THERE WAS A
BEAUTY FROM HERTL.
AND THEN JUST BURNS HAVING T T
NIETTO THE
NET,
WITH 45.
NOBODY TOUCOVERS THAT ONE UP
HE IS ALE
PEDERSON'S GAME TONIGHT.
>> Bret: THAT WAS AN TO GO SHORT
SIDE POWER PLAY AS MIKE YEO'S
TEAM IS
GREGOR INTO BONINO
>> Bret: COUTURE WITH THE
COMES OUT.
WHAT A STOP FROM JAMESITGHT, RE
TO THE FAR SIDE.
I WANTED THIS TO BE OFOF COUTURG
WITH MATT NIETO AND ERIK
KARLSSON T OFF
HE'S GOING TO ATTACK ANYWAY.
NOW HE PEELS BACK AS HERERE
CHANGE
LOVED WHEN KARLSSON HELD ONTO
IT
TOMAS HERTL AND THE SHARKS WIN
IT IN OVERTIME